all right welcome welcome welcome to the
stream this will probably be the last
livestream of the month more than likely
except maybe tomorrow I'll end up with a
little bit of time to stream but it's a
very busy weekend coming up not the
least of which is because of the Super
Bowl an annual tradition here in New
England where the Patriots are playing
maybe we will talk about that if people
want me to but I probably won't do too
much sports on today's stream since my
audience hates it okay what I will be
talking about today are the growing
rumors that Bernie's running I'm going
to talk about already Kappa camel canola
Kamala Harris softening her stance on
medicare-for-all exactly as I predicted
at least some Democrats were going to I
will take super chats we will maybe open
up the phone lines so if this is your
first live stream welcome I'm just
waiting for people to jump on I tweeted
I posted on Facebook I didn't do
Instagram or snapchat the latter because
I don't even know how it works I'm not
on snapchat but we will wait for for
some more people to get connected here
if this is your first live stream these
are live as opposed to all of the other
stuff we put on YouTube which is not
live you can use super chat to ask
questions and send comments I have some
articles I'll be talking about which are
in the video description but I also will
be addressing all questions and comments
sent via super chat which is the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window
one already coming in sign up for
membership there are two coupon codes in
the description for this stream one of
which ends at the end of the month which
is tomorrow night at midnight
that is the code 2019 it'll give you a
60 dollar membership for 20 bucks twelve
twenty dollars in nineteen cents if we
get 10 new members during the stream I
will open up the phone lines it costs us
money every time we do that which is why
we usually have like a new member goal
on the streams people want to call in I
am glad to take phone calls for a while
but we are looking for 10 new members
YouTube members or patron
please don't troll the live chat I
already had to ban one person before we
even started the stream which is
depressing to some degree and yes you
can become a youtube channel member
using the join button which should be
below the live stream so let's get into
the first story which is that of is
Bernie Sanders going to be running for
president in 2020 I have an article
which I was going to go over with you
from the Burlington Free Press let me
mute this because otherwise we are
probably going to get all sorts of ads
there are more and more reports that
indeed Bernie Sanders is getting ready
to announce that he's going to run for
the Democratic nomination in 2020 now
that wouldn't come as a surprise to me
I've actually been saying since when was
it it was in early October I spoke to
two people involved with Bernie I don't
really want to say more because that
they actually could maybe be identified
and they weren't speaking officially but
they said Bernie is planning to run and
that the question was more a matter of
when to announce rather than if of
course that's merely what I was told but
now we are starting to hear more and
more about Bernie Sanders is starting to
ramp up fundraising Bernie Sanders is
getting ready to announce so there's a
couple different things I want to
mention about this number one is that
politically I am right in there with
Bernie
there is no question whatsoever that
Bernie Sanders if you were to run would
be one of if not the most politically
aligned with me candidates
I'm not playing at least at this point
any of the electability games or who
could better who who could better deal
with Trump's campaign style I'm trying
not to get involved in any of that stuff
for the time being because III don't
think we can really win that game we
don't know at this point who is going to
be best positioned to defeat Donald
Trump but that doesn't mean that I think
Bernie is without any problems when it
comes to electability period so I'll say
that
if Bernie were to run would I support
him I've intimated that the the two
candidates who are right now of the
people that are running closest to my
politics they would be Elizabeth Warren
and Andrew yang Andrew yang I will also
mention I I am more and more interested
in and reax candidacy the more I learn
about it he was a guest on the program a
month or two ago maybe longer maybe it's
been like four months time time is we're
in a vortex of time as far as I'm
concerned
suddenly I'm almost 35 right so
something weird is going on with time
but he is going to be on the program
tomorrow and peek behind the curtain the
interview already took place it took
place a few hours ago he's building a
campaign he I am not getting the
impression that he is running not to
insult Richard Oh Jetta but I think that
his campaign is more serious in terms of
its possibilities than Richard Oh Jettas
he has run the numbers in terms of what
it takes to do well in the Iowa caucuses
given the number of candidates and the
number of people that often participate
there so I am very interested in Andrew
Yang's candidacy he told me off air
about some very very important media
appearances that he has coming up in the
next couple of weeks
so if Bernie runs am i a Bernie guy am i
with Elizabeth Warren am i with Andrew
yang I don't know the answer but I think
what's important is that we are getting
a diverse range of offerings in the
Democratic primary already and it's not
diversity for the sake of diversity and
I mean I'm talking about political
diversity here I'm not talking about a
identity diversity I think that it is
good because it's going to become in
such a crowded field important to
distinguish between the policy positions
of these candidates because they do make
a difference and it very often becomes
all about personality and calculations
about electability or whatever else and
I I think that in particular with a
crowded field the calculations
about those issues about those elements
of the campaign electability and
personality are less important than
policy particularly when running against
somebody like Donald Trump so when might
Bernie announce I don't know it seems
like he might announce soon we I hope
that he doesn't announce between now and
tomorrow's show because the conversation
that I filmed today with Andrew yang
does not account for Bernie as a
candidate it's as Bernie as a possible
candidate but we my my instinct is that
if he is going to run he's going to
announce pretty soon because otherwise
he is going to become very late to the
game I don't think Bernie wants to be
like the tenth candidate or the 12th
candidate if indeed we we are going to
have that many let's take a look at what
else is in this Burlington Free Press
article
Vermont's own Bernie Sanders is
reportedly planning to announce his bid
for president yeah we knew that um why
am i unable to scroll here ah there we
go a Sanders according to multiple
unnamed sources in a Yahoo news report
might try another shot at the
presidential campaign he as we know lost
to Hillary in 2016
not without the DNC s involvement the
unnamed sources delved into different
topics revolving around his presidential
run referencing polls that suggest the
Senators popularity and saying there are
plans to kick a 20/20 bit off with an
exploratory committee yeah that's what
we call the soft launch for campaigns so
like Elizabeth Warren formally speaking
technically speaking has announced an
exploratory committee but I think we all
sort of understand unless something
changes she's running and the benefits
of the exploratory committee are that
they allow you to save face if
ultimately you determine I really don't
want to do this if things change and you
decide it's not it's not looking good
for you for example but for all intents
and purposes she's running and it
appears at least according to this
article that Bernie might do the same
thing our revolution a group organized
under Bernie Sanders put out multiple
press releases in January about efforts
by his supporters to gear up for a 2020
presidential run the organization's
website describes its purpose with three
specific goals which are to revitalize
American Demong
krisi empower progressive leaders and
elevate the political consciousness a
free press insights piece examine
potential challenges that Bernie could
face these include reports of sexual
harassment and poor treatment of women
in a 16 campaign as well as the
diversity of other progressive
candidates people can choose over
Sanders okay so we'll see and I'd be
curious to hear from people in the
audience via via super chatter in the in
the regular chat if you so please what
are your feelings about Bernie as a
candidate at this point I have said
politically I am very much aligned with
him and if he runs I will have a very
serious examination that will need to be
made he is by all by all accounts to the
left of Elizabeth Warren how does his
candidacy potential compared with that
of someone like Andrew yang who again I
really like his politics so that that
will be something that we will get into
in much more detail if indeed Bernie
runs let me say let me mention a few new
members and super chats that are coming
in black wave 54 sent a 99 cent super
chat thank you and Ariel Fernandez with
a dollar fifty six super chat I wish I
knew if a dollar fifty six had some kind
of significance that I'm not not aware
of or if it's just a random number but
thanks to both of you I will get back to
Super chats assuming that they come in
and memberships and will answer
questions and will address comments that
come in there I also am up for opening
up the phones if people want to call in
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I am completely
game for opening up the phones but when
we do that it costs us money because of
how our phone system works it's not a
free system so we're targeting 10 new
members YouTube members or patrons ok
you can go to david pakman.com slash
membership if you want a David Pakman
show membership we have 2 coupon codes
in
play today the first coupon code is this
is 2020 I know it says about soon 18 on
the screen that's just to tell you where
the code goes that's a no old code
though the coupon code this is 20 20
saves you 40% off of the membership of
your choice okay so whether you pick the
$6 a month membership or the $60 a year
membership whatever this is 20 20 saves
you 40% but ending tomorrow night at
midnight there is an even better code
and that code is 2019 it's just two zero
one nine that code will drop a $60 a
year membership to only $20.19 we've not
done something like this for a very long
time we did it in January and we picked
up 450 not that's not an estimate we
literally added 450 members in January
with the coupon code 2019 it ends on the
31st at midnight okay so but please take
advantage of that and if you want the
phone lines to open grab a membership
throw in a dollar a month on patreon
become a YouTube channel member for as
little as I think $1.99 is where it
starts and we will open the phone lines
if we get to that okay let's talk about
Kamala Harris it I'm not pleased to tell
you this okay I predicted this would
happen I didn't know who would do it and
Kamala Harris is the first person to do
it the question has been is Medicare for
all the new litmus test for the
Democratic candidates in 2020 okay it's
important to remember that Medicare for
all is not the Democratic party platform
okay if you look at the Democratic party
platform their position on getting
universal health care meaning coverage
for everyone is twofold
a public option in addition to the
for-profit system that we have and a
Medicare opt-in starting at age 55
instead of waiting till 65 when you
become 55 years of age anytime between
then an age 65 you can opt in to
Medicare for all
that's not I'm sorry you can opt into
Medicare that is not Medicare for all
and what I have predicted is that you
were going to see basically every
Democratic candidate pay lip service to
Medicare for all they will say things
like I support Medicare for all
I support Medicare for everybody I think
eventually we are going to have or
something like that but then they will
start to soften their positions by
saying in the short term I think here
are the tweaks to Obamacare that we
should make or in the immediate what I
would do is make these adjustments to
the for-profit health care system that
we have now I am not naive I understand
that whether a candidate says I'm for
Medicare for all period or a candidate
says I'm for Medicare for all but I'm
open to other options and I think fixing
Obamacare is probably simpler to do I
get that either way Medicare for all is
an uphill battle you're going to need
not only the White House but the House
and Senate it's going to be a fight it's
going to take a while to implement it
even though a lot of the infrastructure
is already in place I get that okay but
if you already are softening on Medicare
for all before there is even a single
democratic debate before we're even
close to a single ballot being cast
you're negotiating with yourself or with
insurance companies that are part of the
problem
that's the context unfortunately Kamala
Harris is already doing that okay let's
see if I can play for you and we might
have to sit through an ad and if so
let's see here we're not getting audio
all right because I muted good okay so
we're gonna just stay on mute until we
get past this ad Kamala Harris did a
town hall on CNN on Monday evening she
was asked about Medicare for all and she
said I support Medicare for all and the
the question sort of asked pretty
directly let me unmute here the question
was asked he
are you okay with getting for-profit
insurers out take a listen to how she
answered the question on Monday night
it's your solution to ensure that people
have access to quality health care at an
affordable price and does that solution
involve cutting insurance companies as
we know them out of the equation
I believe the solution and I'm and I'm
actually feel very strongly about this
is that we need to have Medicare for all
that's just the bottom line
pretty straightforward right we we need
Medicare for all that's it I mean we
just did that that's the bottom line and
she said she was proud to say it
unfortunately within like 24 hours of
this she started to be attacked for her
for what she said Howard Schultz started
piling on and there were tweets from
Republicans and as CNN reports as the
furor grew a Harris advisor on Tuesday
signaled that the candidate would also
be open to the more moderate health
reform plans which would preserve the
industry being floated by other
congressional Democrats it represents a
compromise position that rink risks
angering Medicare for all proponents who
view eliminating private health care who
view eliminating private health
insurance as key to enacting their
comprehensive reform so listen uh I I
get it this isn't episode then they
point out her willingness to consider
alternate routes should not cast doubt
on her commitment to the policy of
single-payer system she's softening okay
I'm not saying she's a bad person she
might be she might not be I don't know
she I don't know her I'm not saying
she's the only one to do this and I'm
not saying that being open or not to
other ideas is going to be what
determines whether we do or don't get
Medicare for all in the end need the
House and Senate and a whole bunch of
other stuff but it's January it's
January and why is she why is this
already being clarified the response
here should be we have the system that
my critics are saying is the right
system right people are saying whoa whoa
whoa you're going to get rid of
for-profit health insurance it's not
ultimately
going to be just up to her or whoever
wins in 2020 to keep or get rid of the
for-profit health care system it doesn't
need to be said that she's open to other
ideas if you want Medicare for all and
you can't get it any reasonable person
is going to say well I want Medicare for
all
I don't have the Senate right now I can
make these five improvements to the
system we have let's make them okay most
elected officials are the Ted Kennedy
incremental lists rather than the it's
all-or-nothing burn it all down if I
can't get Medicare for all this doesn't
need to be said okay the what I want to
see Democratic candidates saying when
they are attacked for just very
uncontroversial statements like we
should have the system that's working
really well in most other developed
countries they should say listen I'm not
going to sit here and pay lip service to
for-profit insurance companies that are
a big part of the problem they exist
they have a lot of lobbying dollars
behind them they're not at risk because
I say I support Medicare for all alone
it's going to be a process it's going to
be a negotiation but I'm not negotiating
with anybody right now I'm for Medicare
for all period we all know that the
for-profit insurance companies will
fight it that even with Medicare for all
you will still likely have for-profit
insurance companies available although
of course most people probably would not
opt to get private insurance and that's
it so I am extraordinarily disappointed
to already see her softening on this
it's not the most surprising thing in
the world I predicted it would happen
they're going to pay lip service and
that's what that's that's what it's
going to be and many of them are going
to back off reminder the default for
Democrats should not be assumed to be
support for Medicare for all the
Democratic Party I know I said this ten
minutes ago at the beginning of my rant
and now I'm gonna say it again
the Democratic Party has a position on
their website right now if you go and
look at it under providing universal
coverage I think is what they call the
heading and it says what they want is a
public option and opt-in for Medicare at
age 55
that's nothing like medicare-for-all
it's better than what we have now of
course so anytime we hear any democratic
candidates say they're for Medicare for
all we want to ask more questions and if
they soften like Kamala Harris then we
want to ask even more questions because
it's exactly what I predicted would be
going on okay I've got new members
patrons YouTube subscribers and super
chats to mention so first and foremost
welcome to Rodrigo Clark Rodrigo
thank you you have signed up using the
this is 2020 coupon code on our website
that is one out of ten new subscribers
on the way to opening up the phone lines
tonight what we'll probably be if you're
just joining me the last stream of the
month
Benoist gram or Benoit gram new member
using the coupon code 2019 this is the
biggest coupon code of the year the
coupon code to zero one nine put it in
when you sign up at www.nasa.gov
- the yearly options make sure sixty
dollars a year is selected you hit the
sign up button and then you put in the
code two zero one nine boom drops a $60
membership to $20.19 ends tomorrow night
at midnight and we have two out of ten
new member so far if we get to ten I'll
open up the phone lines all right let's
see what we have going on here for Super
chats and comments Brian Stephen sends a
$2.00 super chat which to that point was
the biggest super chat of the evening
Bernie / Elizabeth Warren or Elizabeth
Warren with bernie is the perfect ticket
I don't know about that Brian I again
I'm not trying to do whose most
electable right now but if we play that
game I don't know that - northeastern
liberals are the right ticket I'm not
saying on policy I love it right
Elizabeth Warren and burn
are the two senators closest to my
politics I don't know that that actually
is the most electable ticket but I don't
even care about that right now we're not
doing electability games right now
Veronica Mehcad avid with a $5 super
chat now the highest of the evening
really enjoy your shows Thank You
Veronica I appreciate your support Ryan
Couture with a $2.00 superjet Howard
Schultz's existence is annoying yeah
listen even if Starbucks Coffee weren't
atrocious and I know why it's atrocious
and it's because anyway we don't need to
talk about why but it's bad he his
presence as a possible independent
candidate would be very very annoying to
me because it's it's if anything is
gonna help Trump win that's it and
because we have this wealth wealth Oh
what would we call it wealth the files
in in our society if you're a
billionaire you get media appearances
and you are treated like you are good
smart and talented merely because you
made a lot of money and that's not
that's not always the case it's often
not the case and I find Howard Schultz's
presence even as a possibility in this
2020 presidential election I find it
annoying I think he's gonna go away
because he's getting crushed by a lot of
people for his mere involvement robber
clobber with a $5 super chat I love
Bernie but his age does worry me a
little which is something Obama had as a
younger candidate aoc is another example
recently huge buzz yeah I mean listen I
don't think it's in appropriate to
consider age when you look at candidates
the age difference between Trump and
Bernie is not that big and the truth is
Bernie appears to be in much better
physical condition than Donald Trump let
me see if I can what exactly their age
difference
so Trump right now June 14 1946 okay and
Bernie Sanders 1941 okay so they're
they're four and a half years apart yeah
but
Trump's obese right I mean unless you
believe that he's 6-3 in ways I think it
was 239 we were told or something like
that
Trump's obese I've seen Bernie play
basketball punch times in the last
couple years I think on health if it's
just on health I I think I still choose
Bernie over Trump but I don't think that
it is incorrect to consider age when
when we think about candidates I'm just
not there right now when Bernie hasn't
even said he's running yet Alejandro
Alvarez with a three dollar and fifty
cent super chat thoughts on the hashtag
never Bernie tag feels like 2016 I have
not seen it used that much I saw some
people on my Facebook friends list using
the never Bernie thing I'm really not
paying much attention to it so you know
I will deal with that if and when Bernie
runs black wave 54 with a 99-cent Super
chat thank you very much appreciate it
Corey Gorski with a ten Canadian dollar
super chat Thank You most right wing
commentators infuse and espouse
philosophy when arguing their policies
you tend to stay away from that line of
argument is it because philosophical
arguments can be easily twisted Corey
thank you okay thank you for asking this
question because this relates to a lot
of what I have talked about on the show
here's the thing about so when you say
they talk about philosophy there's often
too much of a focus on principles here's
the problem with the focus on principles
many on the right and some on the left
but many on the right like to create an
infrastructure for policy where they say
it's all simply their principles and
they will often lay out these very broad
principles like I am for freedom at
every opportunity or something like that
and they like to pretend that if you
simply lay out principles like freedom
and liberty small-government
the non-aggression principle right so
I'm cut now I'm kind of building up
libertarian principles they pretend
sometimes naively sometimes out of bad
faith they pretend that if you merely
lay
your principles clearly enough all of
the policy becomes obvious and clear and
the principles inform what the policy
should be the problem with that is that
most of the tough stuff in life is
because principles don't actually inform
exactly what the policy should be the
devil is almost always in the details
and they like to pretend that it's one
of the most infuriating things they like
to pretend that by very clearly laying
out principles the policy solutions are
going to be obvious for every problem so
I don't stay away from philosophy and
principles as a primary topic because I
think it's irrelevant or because I think
it's not important I read a ton of
philosophy and I think trying to
establish in some kind of objective way
what are our morals and guiding
principles and all of that stuff it's
really really important but it's often a
distraction when it comes to actually
figuring out what policy should be if
you believe in both liberty and freedom
from aggression at a certain point
you're going to have to figure out how
do you balance the two because someone's
Liberty to be aggressive most
libertarians would say stops when you
start to impinge on someone else's
ability to enjoy their life but where
exactly do you draw the line they like
to pretend that the prince of a list of
principles gives you these answers it
doesn't the other reason why philosophy
is really difficult in politics is that
a lot of philosophy much like just
coming up with a bunch of principles
write a list of principles a lot of it
depends on universality meaning that you
are coming up with either principles or
ideas or policies that apply in every
situation it's just not very realistic I
mean even seemingly uncontroversial
black/white principles like killing is
wrong even that does not always apply
and this is not me doing this moral
relativism game where anything can mean
anything listen with moral relativism I
mean yes
degree humans can come down in different
places when it comes to morality but we
are all objective in our morality and
that we are all Homo sapiens we are all
interpreting the world via eyesight
through the human eye and you know the
idea that once you open up the door to
some relativism you're opening up the
door to literally anything that's also
wrong so I try to stay away from these
universals not because I'm a moral
relativist in any particular sense but
because it often just gets us nowhere
it really doesn't tell us about what
should the tax rate be how should we
prioritize spending what should the laws
be around vaccination right I mean a lot
of these things they're simply not going
to be answered with with the universals
anyway core that's a huge rant but that
that's my answer to that Cori let me
welcome Keith Hoyt who is tonight's
third new member if we get to ten I'll
open up the phone lines a rich ropa thak
says with the $5 super chat why is there
such a large number of Jews Chinese
Middle Easterners and Indians in what
ought to be a truly American University
at Brandeis I have no idea I mean I
don't know what's implied in your
question I'm gonna assume you're asking
in good faith I I couldn't tell you why
that's the case at Brandeis I know that
Brandeis is a historically in the same
way that some colleges are historically
black historically black colleges and
universities Brandeis has a sort of
historical Jewish population I guess we
would say and then that that would be a
maybe a factor but I could not possibly
comment on the dynamics of of admissions
practices at Brandeis University School
I've never gone to by the way I went to
Bentley University which is another
Business School in Waltham Massachusetts
but not Brandeis Frank wolf town says if
a Bernese age bothers people
we should have a young minority
progressive like Nina Turner to be the
vice presidential
pick okay well I don't know four I mean
just just because you're bothered by
Bernie's age doesn't necessarily mean
that Nina Turner should be picked merely
for her age not sure not sure I'm with
you there Frank
Justin Davis would Harris win over Trump
voters due to her extreme law
enforcement background and policies I
don't know and I don't care I mean that
I think that that's the wrong game to
play as I said before I just don't think
that I'm increasingly skeptical of
Harris of Kamala Harris because number
one her record is Attorney General in
California has some holes in it that are
concerning to me
um and number two she's already softened
on medicare-for-all as I told you about
15 minutes ago
Yesenia Moreno says Bernie Andrew yang
2020 yang will be 46 in two years that
is actually interesting the idea of
bringing in Andrew yang alongside Bernie
who is a young candidate if you missed
it I mentioned that I recorded an
interview with 20/20 candidate Andrew
yang earlier today it'll air tomorrow
he made a funny comment about being the
opposite of Trump because he's an Asian
guy who likes math versus I guess being
an old white guy who doesn't really know
much about math or writing or reading I
don't know or much of anything at all
our Flores says at what point in your
life had you decided you would be doing
the show full-time were you ever afraid
of it not being successful thanks David
yeah I mean listen art I so I started
the show when I was a junior working on
my bachelor's degree at the University
of Massachusetts and then it continued
just as a hobby when I went into
graduate school where I did my MBA and
as we were getting to the end of
graduate school the show started to make
a little bit of money we had like
part-time staff and I was doing I think
it was two shows a week at the time and
my classmates were becoming financial
advisors I had already done a financial
advising internship absolutely not for
me going into banking some were going
into
audit and sort of like consulting type
stuff that was a popular one at Bentley
when I was graduating I didn't want to
do any of that stuff and what I decided
to sort of do is it's kind of gamble on
the idea that in the short-term they
might have the cushy situation working
for like a big four consultant or who
knows what but that I would maintain
autonomy which was always really
important to me when I've had to work
for like a boss and Ruben we start at
9:05 a.m. and you came in at 9:10 today
and that's really a problem for me that
stuff was never formed for me so I took
a gamble and and I worked some part-time
jobs doing video production and some
other stuff while I grew the show and at
a certain point I said I'm just going to
give this a shot and of course it did
not start quickly this has been 12 years
in the making at this point or even more
but now it's more than full-time for me
we're spinning off an ad agency from the
show because of the success of our ad
sales platform we have multiple
full-time staff so you know obviously it
worked out I still don't have a boss
other than everybody who's watching
right everybody could say we're not
gonna watch we're not gonna contribute
anymore so that's why I mean you know
there's this kind of amorphous thing
where sometimes you hear me say we're
mostly funded by the audience and it's
like yeah yeah yeah no that's literally
true and the reason that I'm still doing
this and that it's been able to grow is
because people say this is good enough
this is this is worth it for me enough
to support it financially so in a sense
I do have bosses but it's not one boss
probably mail telling me I was five
minutes late coming into work yesterday
and yeah afraid of not being successful
I mean even still I I if the show never
grew beyond where it is today
I would be disappointed fortunately
we've had steady growth for for 12 years
but if this was it it would be a
disappointment to me Browdy Andrew
Mulligan says what Bernie's biggest
strength and weakness in your view
strength I would say are his policy
positions and the way that he defends
them economically so when he talked
about Medicare for all he knows exactly
how
it would be paid for when he talks about
free tuition at public colleges and
universities he has a plan for how it
would be paid for do Republicans care no
but he has it and I think that that's a
strengths weakness I think it's it's an
electability thing and I'm not saying he
would or wouldn't have to feed a Trump
I'm just saying he is open to attack
from the right in a bunch of different
ways so was Hillary though and and we
know how that Altima worked out Craig
Adolphe says or Adolph says Sam cedar
says you stole his set to sign design
what do you have to say for yourself if
he actually said that on his show please
send me a clip I want to see that I
admit that I stole it I mean I I
literally he helped me steal it Sam it
is it theft if he helps I contacted him
and I said hey I want to keep a monitor
behind me but I want to mix it up in
some other way when we move studios I
like the thing you have behind you what
how did you build it and he literally
sent me a link to the products he bought
so I can't imagine that he's hugely
surprised and if he actually said David
Pakman stole it he's basically telling
the truth and he condoned it but yeah
the one change I'm thinking of making
and I actually have maybe I can show you
here I have here with me this is this
might look weird on camera but these are
orange you can see kind of some orange
here these are orange gels that I'm
thinking of adding some to add a little
more color because it's all very cool
tones right now on the set so I have
these pieces of lighting gel and I'm
thinking about maybe putting a little
bit of this color maybe on this one
maybe that one there or maybe that that
one down there and and this one here
just to kind of warm up the tones a
little bit but you know nobody likes not
everybody is going to like changes that
we make in fact we often hear more from
people who dislike changes but it's all
worked out in the long run so I think
it's gonna it's going to be okay
let me say thank you to Larry annex --an
who is today's fourth new member during
the stream if we get to ten new members
I will open a
the phone lines woke nation is asking is
it going to hurt Bernie to delay his bid
yeah I think if he delays too much
longer he's going to be behind and every
indication is if he's running I expect
we will hear from him in the next in the
next four weeks Patrick Sweeney says
would Hillary running again be a net
positive in other words splitting the
corporate vote embarrassing herself with
a bad showing love the show man nope I
think Hillary should stay out I don't
think it's a net positive and I think I
think that's it I think there's going to
be plenty of good candidates without
Hillary a richer opa thack follows up
saying a kamala means orange in Indian
languages only fitting she should be the
candidate to take on Trump also should
dave rubin should rave Dubin debate Sam
cedar yeah I'm for the battle of ideas
and more conversation instead of less
and how all of that stuff Dave's war so
yes Dave Rubin should debate Sam cedar
horror fan for life says hey what's your
view on Jesse Ventura great show Jesse
Ventura says some things that make sense
and he also says a lot of really crazy
stuff and I've had him on the show two
or three times and you know I don't find
him to be the most interesting political
player right now dream cloud do you have
plans or have you made plans to go on
the Joe Rogan podcast I have made those
plans Joe is just totally unaware of it
so at some point he's gonna have to
participate if it's going to happen I
would love to go on any time he
retweeted something of mine last month
and I've heard through the grapevine
that Joe is more than just aware of the
David Pakman show
he and comedian Bill burr talked about
an incident that was involved in last
month I won't rehash the whole story now
but I'm ready I'm ready to get on the
plane and head out to LA and time
let's see Comp Sci law says okay
Canadian Americans say universal health
care is bad look at Canada we love our
system wouldn't trade with an outlaw
private wouldn't trade with and outlaw
private care wouldn't trade uh
not exactly sure what what they're
saying but don't allow a hybrid system
yeah I just don't know how you outlaw
private care in the US but if a
single-payer system were good nobody
would get the private care so I think
that problem will resolve itself Orphic
is a new YouTube member the Doomsday
Channel is a new YouTube member which
gets us to six new members during the
stream and Kyle masks has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership with
the coupon code 2019 that gets us to
seven we're getting very close to
opening up the phone lines reminder this
ends tomorrow night at midnight our
memberships normally cost ok the normal
price is $6 a month or $60 for the year
until tomorrow night at midnight if you
use the KU if you select a $60 a year
membership but then type in the coupon
code 2019 2:01 9 you will get a $20 and
19 cent membership for as long as you
want
ok 7 out of 10 if we get to 10 new
members I'll open up the phones people
don't want me to open up the phones no
problem then I won't but if people do we
are just three new members away from
that sir edy Achmed Yehia says is you're
not even going to be affected by the tax
raise a good argument I don't think it
is it's ok so this is a fair question
it's not a great argument in informal
logic right so whether a tax increase or
decrease is a good or bad idea should be
should not be informed by how it will
impact interested parties we should be
able to establish what is the right
level of Taxation in a disinterested
manner and you know I feel like I am
doing an okay job of this because I now
make more money than I did five years
ago and I now make and five years ago I
made more money than I did ten years ago
but I've basically had the same view on
taxation even though the amount of taxes
I pay has gone up over time which is but
we should have a progressive tax system
and we
should have some high marginal tax rate
for really high incomes the top tax
bracket shouldn't start at I think it's
five hundred and ten thousand dollars is
where it starts right now the top tag
there should be higher brackets with
higher marginal tax rates I I would like
to think that I I would take that
position no matter what my income is but
no strictly speaking that's not a good
argument however I think it is fair in
more informal political debate to
mention to people you know that you're
not going to be affected by this and the
only people who are make over five
million dollars a year or whatever the
case may be I think that that can be
effective and sort of informal what we
call a rhetorical argument a woke nation
why don't you combine podcasts with Kyle
and Mike who's Mike Kyle kolinsky I
assume you mean why don't we combine
podcasts listen I know that a lot of
Kyle's audience doesn't like me I know
that a lot of my audience doesn't enjoy
Kyle's style so I think it would be a
bad idea to combine podcasts I don't I
don't exactly know why why we would do
that Stephanie Thomas welcome as a new
member that makes eight new members
during the live stream if we get to ten
I will open up the phone lines
Jennifer Arbuckle Medicare only pays 80%
so grandma and grandpa have to either
pay or get supplemental insurance so
that is where private insurance
companies step in yeah I think that's a
fair point Jennifer which is that I
don't think it's assumed that even with
Medicare for all there's no role for
private insurance there's also no hard
and fast rule that says Medicare can
only pay 80 percent right I mean so if
you look at other countries they've
figured out ways in many of those
countries for the equivalent of Medicare
for all which again is not it's not a
takeover of the health care apparatus
it's a takeover of the health insurance
apparatus it's really important to
understand you can have government
health care or you can have government
health insurance still paying
reimbursing a mix of private and public
health insurance health care providers
but that's a fair point Jennifer there
are many situations in which you would
still have a very clear spot for private
insurance woke nation Mike Figaro Mike
Vig Figueredo the Adaro yeah I butchered
his name at the humanist report yep yeah
I'm familiar with him I don't know if he
i'm not exact time that exactly sure
where his politics are but is he I'm
asking the question not rhetorically but
in totally good faith I'm not a hundred
percent sure if he is exactly aligned
with the the sort of wing of the left
that I sort of consider myself part of
I'm not really sure
welcome to Stephane sin yard or Stefan
or Steven who is the ninth out of ten
new member during today's live stream
one more new member and I will open up
the phone lines okay Faye D with a five
New Zealand dollar super chat hey David
fan and member from New Zealand here how
did you learn to deal with critics and
hatreds I like that you make fun but
does it ever affect you yeah I mean
listen the stuff that we put on air or
that I post on my on my Instagram and by
the way if you're not following me on
Instagram or following the show on
Instagram please do because there's a
bunch of really good we put polls up
there I answer questions on there we've
got behind the scenes content anything
that we put up publicly we've already
sort of vetted if we get something that
we determined to be like a real threat
we have a contact in law enforcement
that that we work with on that stuff you
just kind of get desensitized to it
quite frankly but yeah I mean sometimes
someone will figure out exactly how to
push my buttons and I'll find myself
starting to type out replies online and
then I'm like what am i doing I'm
arguing on the internet with with people
when I have a show where I could
actually talk about politics in a more
productive way I delete it I shut down
my computer throw it out the window and
go read a book and wait for the next day
d can UCLA what do you think of
elizabeth warren's tax plan you know i
have not reviewed it in detail yet I
know that she's proposing this wealth
tax which is very different than an
income tax i've not reviewed it I plan
to and I will I will have a full report
for you but it is very very interesting
to see a member of the Senate propose
something like that horror fan for life
David how is it legal for fake news
Hannity to be so close with Trump while
parroting all of trumps BS seems very
dictator 1984 like super scary LH you
what's LH u LH you I don't know what
that abbreviation is super scary LH u
huh
yeah I'm perplexed by that one yeah I
mean listen it what what crime is being
committed i I just I don't know of any
crime that uh that it's it's disgusting
it's despicable it's concerning that
Hannity a propagandist like Hannity is
in such regular contact with Trump but I
don't know of anything that would make
it against the law okay Christmas alone
e mass alone mass alone E is today's
tenth a new member of the evening so
let's open up the phone lines and see
what's going on a six one seven eight
three zero
4750 is the number you can call in
starting now I have unblocked the phone
line six one seven eight three zero 4750
by all means keep sending super chats
and signing up because I will get back
to all of those but I will take some
phone calls for a little bit and see
what is on people's minds they can be
about anything
no speaker phone please avoid Bluetooth
headsets but plug in headsets usually
are fine six one seven eight three zero
4750 let's see why don't we go to the
let's go to the three two three area
code caller from three to three who's
there hello boy three two three hello
that is you right here um hi David um
big fan of the show thank you I'm caller
um oh I'm really nervous that's all
right it Bernie were to enter the
primary um it's it's pretty obvious at
the Millennial vote needs to get out
there seeing as young thing as he got
more votes and Hillary Clinton and Trump
in the Millennial column do you think
that thing turnout will come about him I
mean 2018 TV decide to run it's all
about turnout we can't say and that's
why I've been pointing this out now for
honestly since Trump was elected this is
all about turnout so predictions about
why one candidate or another would do
well are all conditional and so I don't
have the answer obviously if indeed the
Millennial vote is strong and it goes to
Bernie that's great
if Millennials who tend not to vote in
nearly as high numbers as others don't
get out then it's not going to be much
use oh okay then well thanks for taking
my mic question David all right no
problem you did great
despite being nervous you did very very
well let's go to the four eight zero
area code four eight zero what's going
on hey David it's miles from Arizona I
guess I have a couple of questions my
first one is first did you hear about
Mitch McConnell insulting federal
workers like he said something about
like like when federal workers asked for
a holiday he's kind of like oh it's this
power grab there the Democrats and stuff
miles your connection is atrocious today
I didn't hear that but I am going to
cover the fact that while not
co-sponsoring a bill to get back pay to
all the contractors that weren't paid
during the shutdown he is co-sponsoring
a bill to repeal the estate tax on
families with more than 22 million in
assets to pass on so the guy's
disgusting and despicable okay so
recently someone was talking you about a
bet about Alexander Cassio Cortes
running for president and abets well
forgetting the bet would you want to see
a
see someday run for president I couldn't
putt so based on the knowledge she has
today no I mean most of the candidates
that are currently in the Democratic
primary I believe would be better
presidents than her I still hear her
20/20 I mean like 10 years right
whatever so like miles you're shot out
of a cannon today what I'm telling you
is if in ten years or whenever she's old
enough to run her political knowledge is
such that I feel comfortable then we can
have a conversation about it but we
don't know what that's going to be in
the future you know what I mean yeah I
mean she just seems like a Bernie
Sanders 2.0 but I understand yeah like
ten years plate-like yeah like not
immediately but definitely would want
some stuff down the line I just think
there's great things ahead of her in my
personal opinion she's had to have a big
a big career ahead of her for sure
all right miles thank you appreciate the
call let's go to oh I don't know there's
so many people what let's what area
codes I recognise 305 I think is Miami
and I love Miami Beach so let's call
though I think Miami Beach has its own
area code but in any case 305 who's
there
uh can you hear me David yes I can all
right this is Brian yeah I'm in Miami
cool so I just have a quick question
just regarding how toxic sometimes the
Internet can be you can find this like
on YouTube comments on reddit it's
pretty much everywhere so I just wanted
to know your opinion about how that can
like truly influence a society Oh
completely destructive it's a horrible
the the toxicity of the internet the way
people engage on Twitter I mean what
you've got to remember is even most of
the most toxic people on the internet if
you put them physically in front of the
people that they're bullying online
they're going to behave in a much more
reasonable manner not everybody bad
there are people who do bad things in
real life too but I think that the way
internet political debate
happens is one of the most destructive
and toxic forces in our politics today
so if you don't mind me just like
quickly asking how would you suggest
kind of like getting that balance
between living in you know the world
where you could utilize technology and
also kind of like staying genuine so you
could actually get something done you
know all the trolling you just like a
lot of hate I mean I'm only starting to
read it but I would check out Cal
Newports actually I don't even know if
this book is out I might just have a
review copy it may not even be out the
book is called digital minimalism and
it's all about exactly what you're
talking about sort of like developing
healthy social media use and consumption
and we're scheduled to interview him I
don't even know when next week the week
after I'm not sure but I think that an
approach like that is really what is the
healthiest thing all right thank you so
much for your time all right we she ate
the call great to hear from you let's
see let's go to the 202 area code
I think 202 is the nation's capital is
that right that is right what's going on
I like that ding you announced your
entrance with a ding yeah that was my
computer um I have a question well what
would Larry at home Ian and/or John
Kasich and a Republican primary mean for
Donald Trump I've heard that there are
some people who want to just give the
from Republican primaries all together
but there are quite a few people who
don't our Felipa like susan collins
maybe don't take my holy word on that
does not want Trump on the 20/20 ticket
and so what would like Larry Hogan or
John Kasich primary and Trunk mean for
him could they actually beat him listen
they could if the Republican Party at
the Senate and House level is with Trump
it's gonna be very difficult to win a
primary against the sitting president
okay so I don't I wouldn't get
expectations up but that doesn't mean
that particularly Kasich can't damage
Trump if Kasich pulls Trump into
Kasich can get enough support to at
least cause Republican primary debates
to happen for a sitting president to
have to do primary debates would be very
damaging because it's only downside
right he's not gonna and Trump's not
gonna win Democratic votes by having to
debate John Kasich but he might lose
some Republican votes so I think it's
gonna be insanely unlikely that a
Republican beats Trump in the primary
unless the party abandons him but it can
only possibly weaken him and for that
reason I support it also two other
things one Larry Hogan is actually a
business success and I could see him
going after Trump or beat because Trump
has bankrupted there's an internet video
10 of Donald Trump businesses I
completely failed Larry Hogan is a
business success story and he could use
that against Trump yeah and what do you
think about that yeah maybe he could he
could say at least my businesses haven't
gone bankrupt he had at least one and it
was fantastic also fun history fact
there's only one president who's ever
lost their own primary upon reelection
and that was Franklin Pierce whoa there
you go I did not know that thank you
thank you for sharing that fact all
right have a great day okay thanks you
too sounded like speakerphone but it was
good enough that I wasn't going to delay
the phone call with with that okay let's
go and let's go to 9 1 7 area code 91 is
9 1 7 New York yeah it is David nice
what's going on how's it going um so my
question is do you think we should
nationalized all inelastic goods not
from a sense of morality but as a sense
of you know if it's cheaper shouldn't a
government you know control that
function if profits gonna you know make
them more expensive like a good example
of this is health care water going into
people's houses you know III just don't
think things like broadband internet or
other inelastic goods and services
should have a property very good
question so let's first let's I'll
explain to the audience an inelastic
good
or what we're talking about is goods
within goods and services with inelastic
demand when demand is elastic when the
price goes up significantly demand goes
way down so if all of a sudden avocados
cost $20 each way fewer people would be
demanding avocados health care for
example is inelastic in the sense that
basically you're either in need of
health care services or you're not the
demand is not elastic with price even if
all of a sudden I don't know
antibiotics become crazy expensive
you're not going to see decrease demand
because people don't take antibiotics
for fun you either need antibiotics or
you don't my concern is I I don't know
if I would say all inelastic goods
because there might be counter examples
there might be inelastic goods that
there's not a strong case for the
government to get involved in I mean
certainly with healthcare I agree with
you but I'd have to think about it there
might be some examples where I would not
be on board but I've not really
considered it in those terms okay I
think your answer David it's not more a
quick thing you know considering how bad
the weather is right now I don't think
we bad as Boston but New York's very
very windy and snowy today I've had a
couple I have a couple Trump his friends
and family members would like to point
out that just because the weather is
cold you know that obviously is nothing
to decline it but they say Oh
global warming is really kicking it now
what's a good rebuttal for that take
them out of your life yeah I wouldn't
talk to those people okay
yeah I mean listen it's you know weather
versus climate it's two different things
we dealt with it yesterday but at this
point if people still believe that it's
like you know that that's probably
someone that is more of a problem than
then they're probably dragging you down
more than they're lifting you up would
be my my guess I think that's what I
needed to hear thank you all right take
care let me know if you do cut anybody
out though let's see a lot of people on
the phone today why don't we go to all
right let's all go to a a prior caller I
haven't heard from Grover for
what's going on Grover okay David hey
what's up how you doing good baby
I don't like cute things let you know so
first of all I amazing show by the way
and the thing is um the I have seen your
ads playing for the better help just to
let you know and to catch up with you
see I'm yes I know you don't watch um
YouTube there was a whole issue of a
better help so that's a suggestion I
will watch out for that particular yeah
yeah so that we I'm aware of that issue
the they're basically there were two
issues with with better help during
which we suspended all ads for them
until these issues were resolved okay
the first issue is that people said you
know the terms and conditions for better
help say this is one of our advertisers
for people who don't know what Grover is
talking about the terms and conditions
said that better help was not ultimately
responsible if the credentials of one of
their online therapists was not what
they claimed it to be and this was
misunderstood as better help doesn't
verify credentials so better help has
now updated their terms and conditions
and what they've explained is that they
do verify that every single one of their
therapists is not only licensed in the
state where they practice but also has a
thousand hours of clinical experience
that disclaimer is a very legal thing
uber has something that's identical for
their drivers and what happens is all of
these companies initially do verify the
credentials licensing insurance whatever
of their service providers but they for
legal reasons they put that in because
imagine that a month after a new
therapist or uber driver is accepted
into the system they lose their
credential for whatever reason better
help wouldn't immediately know that and
so for legal reasons they put that in
there but they've clarified that issue
the other one was about like a
money-back guarantee
and they've now also added that into
their terms and conditions so I'm
reasonably satisfied that those issues
have been taken care
so that's why they're back to
advertising with us okay thank you
and on last one I wanted to say that I
have been spraying your show I don't
want to say but as a joke I would just
say as herpes but it's a joke don't take
it too serious sorry you won't you've
explained that the show has herpes
no no I'm spreading your show like
herpes herpes oh good good I hear that
that spreads really quickly it's never
gotten me fortunately but I do hear it
spreads very quickly Grover great to
hear from you thank you thank you all
right
before I pick up on a couple other folks
Brian Walters new member on YouTube
thank you Roy Earle says David I
generally agree with you and Kyle on
politics but lately he's been a maduro
apologist I feel like Kyle is being
sympathetic to the Leninist left to a
diluted degree I hope that's not true
I've not seen anything he is said about
it again I don't not watch YouTube like
Grover said but I basically watch what
do i watch on youtube i watch chess
videos chess streamers i watch some
comedy videos i watch live concerts for
bands that I like but I don't not watch
YouTube I just don't really watch
political shows I've not seen what he's
saying I am NOT an apologist for the
Maduro regime I am against authoritarian
dictators and so I'm against Nicolas
Maduro Harvey says what ever happened to
Michael avenatti he seemed to dropped
off seems to have dropped off the face
of the media spotlight wonder why he's
not baiting Trump anymore yeah I mean he
was accused of sexual assault arrested
released I don't know what happened but
he was not a particularly positive
character in the world of politics so it
may not be altogether a bad thing let's
go to the phones to the five-three-one
area code 531 what's going on hi this is
Henry from Lincoln Nebraska how are you
David good thanks for calling all right
so I'm a first-time caller so a little
off-guard but I was curious after seeing
that comment what you think about
Venezuela I listened to Kyle a lot and
most of what he says is to do with oil
it's not I was just kind of curious what
you think the motivations are behind our
actions there which actions have we
taken they're just inciting the coup
[Music]
that way oh just you know I'm not I was
just kind of curious about what you
think about the whole matter look as far
as like intention the United States has
right well so okay let's let's see if we
can separate these issues there is no
doubt that the u.s. gets much more
interested in countries when there's oil
in controlling or influencing who is in
power and there's no question that
American involvement in Latin America
has been disastrous for decades the
problem is that I'm a progressive so I
am for institutions of democracy I'm for
free press an independent judiciary and
standards of living that we can be proud
of as opposed to be horrified by so I'm
against Nicolas Maduro I'm for
legitimate elections and Nicolas
maduro's actions of repressing
opposition candidates and what was by
all indications a completely bogus
reelection I'm against all of that so I
am against Nicolas Maduro
I was against Hugo Chavez that is not
the it's populist leftist rhetoric
veiling or hiding an authoritarian
regime okay so that's that's number one
now the u.s. involvement can be bad to
be criticized all of that stuff but we
can still say Maduro x' got to go right
so I think that the problem that some
people are left are falling into and I
have no clue what Kyle has said right
I'm just going off of emails that I get
from from people the problem is just
because we don't like Trump and Trump is
recognizing the interim president
doesn't mean we should be supporting
Nicolas Maduro because he's a train
wreck
okay well thank you for the detailed
response I had one little thing if
that's all right yeah I remember a while
ago someone mentioned that they had a
Infowars bumper sticker somewhere in
public and you sent them a bumper
sticker of your own to cover it up right
I've had one at my college for a long
time and so I was wondering if there's a
way I could reach out to you about
covering that up
so listen Infowars is dead so I don't
know if we should prioritize covering up
Infowars bumper stickers anymore
but if I'm in touch I will still send
you one although I question whether
there might be better bumper stickers we
could be covering up now yeah all right
thank you all right no problem D can
UCLA sent a super Chad have you noticed
the last five Republican presidents or
criminals Nixon Watergate Reagan's
iran-contra scandal George HW Bush a war
criminal George W Bush a war criminal
and Trump too many to list what are your
thoughts yeah I mean listen um all
presidents make decisions that lead to
people dying through foreign policy that
doesn't mean that george w bush is not a
war criminal or that George HW Bush is
not a war criminal I just think that not
everything you know like with the me to
movement things are at different levels
and I think also when it comes to
presidential criminality without
defending anybody there's also different
levels but you're not wrong do you can
UCLA and and I appreciate the comment
all right I'm out of time I'm sorry I
was not able to get to everybody who's
waiting on the phones including the 13
people that are waiting
really appreciate everybody who signed
up contributed today sent super chats
all of that stuff I will do another
stream soon I don't know if in January
but definitely early in February if that
if tomorrow night doesn't work out
thanks for joining me